cowboys had some pretty significant
needs on the offensive line that line is
getting older and it is getting fragile
and there's only one offensive lineman
who's been drafted but they instead
focus on the defensive side of the ball
the same week in which sean lee retired
they add an inside linebacker in michael
parsons from penn state a guy who will
make that defense better things brings a
grit brings a toughness brings a level
of talent that they need if they're
going to not have to score 40 or 50
points a game against some of the teams
they play that defense was just abysmal
last year so it's that seattle scheme
with dan quinn it's a bobby wagner type
of a presence in michael parsons and the
cowboys moving toward addressing a
significant need on the defensive side
of the ball they've got other needs on
defense but they went with a glaring one
and they decided to wait for now on the
temptation to address an offensive line
that definitely needs some help because
it's not what it used to be the defense
far from what it was back in the days of
the doomsday unit now maybe it'll be a
little bit better or not nearly as bad
as it was in 2020.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports